so it's funny big data has been kind of
a cliche in Silicon Valley for the last
few years big data this big date of that
big data is really one big mountain of
garbage with little gems buried in this
you know tremendous trash heap and you
want to find those gems you really want
to find out what's gonna make the
experience better so there are a lot of
sophisticated machine learning
algorithms that Netflix and other
companies deploy to really figure out
what's the one of the gems that are
gonna make a better experience and
what's the rubbish that you want to
separate out and push to the side once
you find those gems what it does is it
doesn't make it a more alienated less
you know more machine experience it
actually makes it a more personal
experience it becomes much more about
the individual member when I first got
to Netflix we were looking at other
companies that were doing
personalization and leveraging the kinds
of data they could learn from and one
company that obviously wasn't
competitive with Netflix was also doing
some interesting things was Pandora the
music company and Netflix is in Silicon
Valley and they're up in Oakland not too
far away and we're down in the South Bay
so we went up to you and we had a
meeting a little powwow there's many
years ago with Pandora and they were
really small then and Netflix was much
smaller and we were just comparing notes
what was interesting about Pandora is
Pandora had the you know the Music
Genome Project where they were tearing
apart and deconstructing lots of music
on all these different dimensions and
trying to really understand the music
and I remember back in these days and
there's like 10 years ago they had their
walls lined with CDs all over and they
had a whole line of people in this
cramped office with headphones on and
they were listening to music with this
big spreadsheets open and tagging
everything about it at that time at
Netflix we were all about rating our
titles on a one to five star system and
we were very much using a lot of
behavioral a lot of algorithms around
the behaviors of what users were doing
and based on some a lot of clustering
techniques we weren't really
deconstructing the titles yet we would
get to that soon after
they weren't really deploying a lot of
the collaborative filtering models that
we were using on our algorithms so we
compared notes and we influenced each
other and we only met a couple of times
with them and we were paying attention
to what other companies were doing in
terms of personalization and based on
these learnings everyone kind of evolved
across it's not just Netflix other
companies that are trying to leverage
big data to make it much easier to find
something great to watch great to listen
to great to read great to buy and figure
out how to use when to use human created
data a lot of metadata a lot of
deconstructing of what the material is
people are watching or listening to or
reading and so forth and how to use a
lot of behavioral clustering data what
kinds of people are watching these kinds
of shows and movies what kinds of people
are watching these or listening to these
and so forth so it wasn't just Netflix
it's just we are very mano maniacally
focused at Netflix and we really want to
get we want to create great content and
we want to get that great content to the
right people at the right time and so
that's why we're using the data let me
throw in one more thing there are a lot
of great companies deploying a lot of
interesting techniques you know not only
in Northern California but around the
world and so right up the road from
Netflix you have companies like Google
and Facebook and they can be great
partners for Netflix at times and there
are brilliant people working there but I
don't envy their jobs because their jobs
are different than what myself and my
team have to do when we have all this
data we have one purpose for this data
and that's to make each individual
members experience better there are no
advertisers or only subscription and in
a subscription model you use everything
you can and you're basically on your
knees and you're saying please stay with
Netflix stay another month it's a great
experience there's lots of great stuff
to watch here's another great TV show or
movie but if you're at a Google or a
Facebook you're doing really interesting
work but you're serving two masters
you're serving the consumer and you're
conserving the advertiser so when you're
getting all that big data you're
constantly you know in this conflict of
do I use this big data to serve the
advertiser and put the right advertising
in front of the right
where to get them to buy something that
they didn't necessarily come to the
service for or am i serving the customer
showing them the right thing in their
newsfeed showing them the perfect search
result and so forth so they're very you
know they're they're incredible tools in
the modern age whether I'm using Google
search or using the Facebook newsfeed
but once again they're there even at a
more perplexing challenge we just use
the data to serve each individual member